hi everyone welcome thanks for coming
thanks for those of you who read all the
way through the title and still came my
name is Jonathan I'm a software engineer
on the Google doodle team and we're here
to talk about how we built our first big
multiplayer game the 2018 Halloween
doodle and there you go okay so we've
divided our story into three parts I'm
gonna give you some background and talk
about how we approach the design process
then Joseph is gonna talk about
designing the open match matchmaker and
then Brian is going to talk about how we
scaled up and launched our production
backends so doodles who are we and what
are we talking about our job is
basically to use technology to make
Google fun to surprise and delight our
users when we talk about doodles we mean
this the illustrations animations and
games that replace the Google logo to
celebrate notable people events and
holidays here a few examples of ways
we've explored web technology in the
past our first game was pac-man in 2010
it's still one of our most popular
nothing like peeking early in 2012 we
built the synthesizer to celebrate
Robert Moog using the new Web Audio API
people can make four track recordings
and share them with their friends in
2016 we decided to try mobile
development celebrate the Olympics we
built a series of sports minigames into
the Google app on Android and iOS so
that brings us to Halloween 2018 which
is the subject of this talk for this
doodle we decided to tackle a new
challenge
multiplayer whole world searches on
Google every day what if we could give
all those people fun way to interact
with each other so right off the bat we
have a few problems to deal with first
off we're not multiplayer game
developers all of our previous games ran
entirely in the user's browser we don't
know how to build and run a fleet of
game servers and we don't have any
experience with cloud platforms that's
unfortunate because we have a lot of
users and we're
mean a lot of servers also most of our
users aren't gamers or at least they
didn't come to play they came to search
and finally we're a very small team how
are we possibly gonna pull off such a
big project well we did it anyway we ran
for two days and 62 countries and we got
a hundred million players so how do we
get there first thing we had to learn
was how to do multiplayer at all so we
had a hackathon see what we could do in
a week we ended up with this tank combat
capture the flag game we had a play test
at the end of the week and we knew we
had something when people started
shouting at each other across the room
so now we had some idea how to do
multiplayer and we needed to focus on
the second problem which is how to
design for our audience our target
demographic is everyone who uses the
internet which is pretty broad and we
generally go for acute art styles and
try to find simple mechanics that are
fun for everyone and the way we do that
is through a process of rapid
prototyping and frequent play tests
here's a couple of the prototypes that
didn't make the cut so what does that
mean for our multiplayer doodle because
our users didn't necessarily come
seeking a game we wanted to get them in
and out as quickly as possible we also
wanted to avoid direct user to user
interactions for a couple reasons first
PvP is not really on brand for us
remember this whole game is basically a
glorified corporate logo so second we
wanted a mechanic that wouldn't be
frustrating for people on slow
unreliable or high latency networks
finally we wanted to keep the backends
as simple as possible both because of
the massive scale and because this was
our first time trying this project was
ambitious enough already
so these considerations led us to make
some technical decisions which shaped
the design of the game we'd have a short
but exciting matches with relatively few
players but massive numbers of them
using highly parallelizable game server
instances we keep matchmaking complexity
to a minimum
we just wanted players to play on the
closest servers to keep latency down and
we could rely on the cloud load balancer
to handle that
for us we didn't need fancy skill based
matchmaking or stat keeping since it's a
super casual game and it's only live for
two days anyway
game server instances could be
short-lived since there's no player
progression or stateful world we could
create and destroy servers as needed to
meet player demand our first prototype
architecture was as simple as we could
possibly make it
we used nodejs for our game server so
that we could write everything in
JavaScript and share code between client
and server communications were handled
by WebSockets and we kept the client as
simple as possible it sent player input
to the server and rendered server
updates as they arrived all game logic
happened on the server at this point we
know working prototype it starts to
become apparent that our system didn't
scale well past about one developer we
were running game servers by SSA Qing
into a cloud VM and running node on the
command line each developer manually
managed their own single VM and we had
no automation or configuration or
maintenance and no easy way to scale up
up to more servers so we need to figure
out how to do it for real we started
researching the Google cloud platform
mark Mandel who you'll hear from if you
come back for the next talk introduced
us to kubernetes via his blog series
scaling dedicated game servers with
kubernetes kubernetes would solve
several problems it would give us an
easy way to configure manage and scale
our game servers and it would also help
with the development process once we had
containerized the game servers we could
easily run the same containers locally
and in the cloud which brought our
development environment much closer to
production this allowed us to separate
back-end infrastructure development from
development of the game itself so here's
what things look like once we had
converted to kubernetes game clients
connect to a matchmaker this is not yet
open match it's just a very basic node
server that keeps a queue of clients in
memory when enough clients are queued to
form a match the matchmaker uses the
kubernetes api to launch a new game
server the clients then connect directly
to the game server and they play when
the match is over game server shuts
itself down so this architecture was
good enough to let us scale up and
load testing this allowed us to begin to
estimate the resources we'd need for our
full-scale production and to answer a
very important question can we actually
afford to do this launch at all it also
let us begin doing some debugging of
client and server behavior and scale
making sure the system behaved well in
the face of client disconnects and
reconnects clients who went through
matchmaking but never connected to the
game servers clients on bad networks all
the fun stuff that happens in the real
world so things were starting to look
good but we still had a lot of questions
and we knew our homespun matchmaker
couldn't scale so we called in the
professionals
hello I'm Joseph and I work for Google
cloud platform the other two gentlemen
you'll hear from today both worked on
the doodle so Google is working with the
games industry we're focused on helping
developers succeed and cloud is really
at the center of those efforts we want
to help you create great games connect
with players globally and scale your
business so we're working with all the
other Google teams to try and bring that
vision to life
so in 2016 the doodle team first
approached us with this idea of we want
to make a multiplayer game so we had a
couple of meetings over the first year
when they were still kicking around the
idea and we identified the same
challenges that Jonathan already
mentioned which is they had pretty
limited experience with multiplayer
backends but also we recognized there
was a big strength in that their team
was small and unified the backend and
the client teams could very easily you
know go over to each other's desk and
help make game design decisions that
could make the backend actually simple
enough to scale for a hundred million
players so in the end they had a very
simplified scope which made it feel like
it was going to be possible to build
this even with a limited runway and a
small team so the doodle team was going
to be responsible for the game client
and the game servers for hosting the
match the multiplayer sessions and cloud
myself in this case took on a task to
build a prototype matchmaker and make
sure that that would in general work and
then eventually help them build a
production matchmaker on top of open
match so the initial design we started
with very basic practices we wanted to
start with what works for other
companies we knew that the scale for a
doodle could be
unbelievably huge even by the standards
of I previously worked as some pretty
big game companies on very successful
triple-a titles even compared to those
we knew that the number of people who
show up to the Google search landing
page every day is well beyond that so we
had to keep thoughts about how to scale
this kind of at the front of our minds
so our first suggestion was to get
everything on kubernetes from the very
beginning we really liked as Jonathan
said before the fact that once you're
using kubernetes in your development
process then you're already in a really
good place where development looks a lot
like what you're going to put on
production and that can really help
accelerate your development so putting
everything in docker containers from the
very GetGo was a big recommendation of
ours and then make the only platform
service for this game which is the
matchmaker make it a stateless as
possible
so that you can scale up and down the
API just to handle however many players
show up so to talk about matchmaking we
really wanted to help them with the
design so there were some decision
points these were things that we had to
come up with a good answer for because
they're it's really going to affect the
complexity of your matchmaking code so
how is the doodle going to handle if
players don't show up does the doodle
support backfilling games if a player
leaves mid-game do you go find another
player to put in can players join in
progress if there's free slots on the
server are there multiple queues for
people to queue in to play with
different kinds of people are there
different regions that you can queue for
so that you only play with people
locally so in pretty much every decision
in the in this slide the doodle team
went for making something as simple as
possible which turned out to really pay
dividends because the whole process went
pretty smoothly as Brian's going to
describe later doodles considerations
being horizontal scalability really did
inform the decisions to
trying keep more complex scenarios like
allowing people to join games in
progress off the table the one thing
that they did want in there was the
ability to have public versus private
games so you would be able to get an
invitation that you could send to your
friends to have them join directly your
game but we just ended up making those
into two completely separate pools of
players failover domains was the thing
that we were concerned about like what
happens if heaven you know forbid
there's an internet issue or something
is unreachable for a certain part of the
player population well it turns out they
were able to solve that just by putting
everything behind a global load balancer
and Brian will speak to that some more
and another slide so quickly let me go
through a breakdown of how a single
matchmaking instance worked for the
doodle from left to right so there's a
client facing API that the game clients
talk to directly that takes information
about that player and writes it to a
Redis instance then the matchmaking
logic comes along and reads from Redis
once it finds enough players to make a
match it persists that match to a cloud
pub/sub topic which is actually
persistent data storage layer at this
point so once you have put a message
into cloud pub/sub it is guaranteed to
be delivered so there's no easy way to
lose it once you've already done the
work of matching players together so
there's a server facing API that the
game servers connect to once the game
server connects it asks the server
facing API to go and fetch a new match
from the pub subtopic and return it to
the game server and at that point the
players get a message out the client
facing API all the way on the Left that
tells them the IP and how to connect
over WebSocket to the game server
directly that is not pictured on this
slide but there is a return path for
getting it back for anyone here who as
actually looked at open match you may
notice that there's some differences in
the way things are named here so doodle
was using open match before open match
was even announced so by the time we
worked closely with unity to get it out
the door the zero point one version we
tried to come up with slightly more
generic names for the api's that did a
better job of describing scenarios that
were not doodle specific so now I'm
gonna turn it over to Brian he's going
to talk about production izing the
doodle all right thanks Joe
so I'm Brian Murray I'm a software
engineer on the doodle team and I was
lead back-end engineer for the Halloween
doodle so first some unique challenges
we had to face along the way with
doodles we don't have the luxury of a
soft launch where we can gradually
increase traffic over time we basically
have to go from zero traffic to all of
Google search instantaneously which
turns out to be difficult and since we
run doodles on google.com any downtime
would be really bad it could put the
project in jeopardy because we can't
exactly just move Halloween back a
couple days but luckily we only had to
keep this thing alive for 48 hours so
unlike most game developers who have to
support a project for months or years we
only had to stay awake for two days so
I'll just briefly run through our
back-end infrastructure you may remember
a similar diagram from earlier this is
what we started with then we met Joe he
built us a matchmaker and this is
essentially what the inside of our
clusters look like at launch when we
needed to scale up capacity we picked
regions around the globe to start
clusters in we connected them to clouds
global load balancer and then we just
let it balance the traffic
geographically we didn't have any custom
logic for routing people to different
regions and when we needed to scale it
further we just added more clusters
so here we have a list of all of the
tools and technology that we use to
develop the backends as you can see here
everything that we used is available
externally
there's no Google specific internal
magic behind the scenes and even the way
we interacted with cloud was very
similar to how an external customer
would have interacted with them so go a
little bit into our development process
for those that are interested we
separated our development into two GCP
projects one for production one for
development and we kept all of the
resources separate between these
projects which ensured that anything we
were doing in development wouldn't
suddenly break production and within our
development development project we had
our own clusters for development so I
had a cluster Jonathan had a cluster we
had a cluster for load testing and it
was really important that we had no
special configuration for these they
were basically production clusters but
we wanted to make sure that behavior in
these clusters were as as close to prod
as possible and finally we wanted to
make the process of creating and
destroying them really easy because when
you end up in a weird state after hours
of debugging the last thing you want to
do is to have to figure out you know how
do I fix this in real time it's nice to
be able to just throw everything away
and start from scratch
so we wrote a couple of scripts to make
this process easy okay so we have a game
we have a plan for how to scale things
how do we actually figure out how many
servers we need so in our case we knew
roughly how much traffic to expect by
looking at numbers from previous doodles
we knew how long our games were and if
we combine these two we could use some
basic math to estimate how many people
would be connected at a given time so we
did that we extrapolated a little bit
and we came up with an initial estimate
we knew our numbers wouldn't be perfect
but we just hope that they would be
close enough just to get a rough idea of
how much traffic to expect okay so now
we have our initial estimate we need to
figure out if we can actually handle
that much traffic so we wrote a custom
client a headless client to simulate the
process of
connecting to the matchmaker joining
into a game playing through it and then
disconnecting and then when we wanted to
run load tests we just started a bunch
of these in a kubernetes job pointed it
at our load test cluster and then let
him run wild and our strategy throughout
this whole process was to start really
small only scale up when we are
confident that the system could handle a
given amount of traffic so here we have
a quick example we have ten clients per
second pointed a cluster here when we're
confident that it can handle that much
traffic we scale that up to 20 looks
good at 20 so we go to 30 and then in
this example we noticed that at 30
clients per second our matchmaker starts
having issues so let's say our CPU usage
is spiking
we investigate we decide that we just
need more matchmakers so we had more we
rerun our tests we make sure that it's
stable and if everything looks good we
carry on and then occasionally we would
run longer tests because there are
certain things that you can only figure
out after maybe 10 or 12 hours of load
that you wouldn't be able to see in an
hour test so we would run tests for 12
hours or 24 hours to verify that these
issues weren't happening and finally
since our estimates initially were
pretty rough we wanted to make sure that
we ran load tests well above our peak
traffic numbers our expected peak
traffic numbers and so in our case we we
scaled up our load tests to double what
we expected at peak traffic and that
basically gave us an idea of what would
happen if the doodle went viral okay so
we're ready for production at this point
we set up monitoring and alerting so
that we can have some visibility into
how the launch is going we switched from
running Redis internally in our clusters
to using cloud memory store and that
provided us better guarantees of
reliability
it gave us people we could talk to if
issues came up and then we also worked
with cloud professional services to come
up with a launch plan they helped us
with stuff like capacity planning
reserving resources setting up on-call
rotations that kind of stuff okay
launch time time to turn everything on
and hope for the best
so we wanted to spin up our clusters far
enough ahead of time to ensure that they
were stable before the doodle actually
went live on the other hand we didn't
want to give too much lead time because
running 36,000 CPUs doing nothing is
kind of expensive since we were only
running for two days we gave ourselves
about three hours to wrap everything up
I would like to have maybe four or five
but it was almost enough from there we
just kept a close eye close eye on
stackdriver and if any metrics came up
that we hadn't planned on stackdriver
allowed us to create dashboards for
those in real-time which was really nice
we worked with cloud professional
services to fix any issues as they arose
and as I mentioned earlier we scaled our
load tests up to double our expected
peak traffic while our average load
ended up being about double what we
expected so it was really valuable to
have seen how the system dealt with this
amount of traffic beforehand as opposed
to having to deal with that for the
first time on launch day we had to add a
couple more clusters to compensate
luckily though the process for spinning
those up only took about 15 minutes and
so it ended up not being that big of a
deal and we were able to do that without
any downtime and other than that the
launch went pretty smoothly so just a
quick summary to wrap things up our
back-end and front-end engineers worked
very closely together and that fact was
very valuable because the close
communication helped us avoid a lot of
design churn and it kept our kept our
final designs simple I know this is a
cloud sponsored talk but as a team that
doesn't normally think about cloud at
all or work with cloud at all we found
it a really solid base for this type of
project we never had to manage any VMs
migrate Services deal with downtime and
the cloud documentation made kubernetes
surprisingly easy to learn
speaking of kubernetes kubernetes Cooper
Nettie's made our scaling process a lot
simpler which was really useful on
launch day once we had our clusters
configured it was easily it was easy to
just start more of them to handle the
unexpected load and we can do that
without downtime
and lastly just a shout-out to Nita mang
who is our contact from cloud
professional services she did a lot of
work to help make sure this launch went
smoothly and she was a huge part of its
success and if you're interested in
learning more Google cloud wrote up a
blog post about the project which you
can find if you google Halloween doodle
GCP and if you want to play the game you
can go to google.com slash doodles and
it'll be in our archive page thank you
[Applause]